Thank You mr. president Cordelia Lynch
Sky News you're a man who likes to win
but last night was not an absolute
victory for you beyond it I'll be honest
I thought it was a I thought it was a
very close to complete victory when you
look at it from the standpoint of
negotiation when you look at it from the
standpoint of deal-making because it's
all about deal making again if we had
the majority and we had one or two or
three votes to play with
we would never we would have been at a
standstill I really believe that we have
a chance to get along very well with the
Democrats and if that's the case we can
do a tremendous amount of legislation
and get it approved by both parties so I
consider it to be hey look I won Georgia
President Obama campaigned very hard in
Georgia Oprah Winfrey campaigned very
very hard all over the television I said
this is going to be tough I only had me
I didn't have anybody else and I went to
Georgia and we had one of the largest
crowds that anybody here has seen ever
at a political rally and you know what
he won anyone actually by a pretty good
margin he won and then we went to
Florida and they had celebrities all
over the place and a man who happens to
be a very smart person was running Ron
de santis and people didn't give him a
chance and I went and we had we did some
great work and they're gonna have a
great governor of the state of Florida
and then we talked about the Senate and
a lot of money was pouring in for the
Democrat this is a man who's been in
office for like 44 years or something
this a man who's like a professional at
getting elected and being at office so
he's not bill nelson not easy to beat
okay and but they had a lot of celebrity
coming out for nelson they had everybody
coming out for nelson and rick Scott won
and I helped him and I think we've done
an amazing job and you could look at
many other places you just take a look
at some of the other places
and we just got the word that in Iowa
you have a governor who just got
extended
who's Fanta Kim just got extended and
and numerous other places I think it was
a great victory I'll be honest I think
it was a great victory and actually some
of the news this morning was that it was
in fact a great victory but if you look
at it from the standpoint of gridlock
I really believe there's going to be
much less gridlock because of the way
this is going than any other